yeah hello and welcome to this video
let's play some games where are we going
with this here right
yes
gotten some rating points back YouTube
yet another Cheatham and they're already
suspected in the last session there was
a cheetah last game of the cheetah so I
got those points back let's see what
Hendra Johan is going to play a lost one
game against um and quite remember this
anyway let's see
Oh
[Music]
to do this this place laughs I haven't
done that for ages I've played them here
the a6 variation a lot
like in the day the chip and ink or Slav
and as far as I know it's still a pretty
good opening you don't see it a lot on
the top level at all and quite know why
you ask me
I mean what white is doing here fields a
bit odd like
is giving me the c4 pawn and where
exactly is the compensation I don't know
the question is how do we play this we
should be seven maybe yeah I think right
is just a pawn down here for basically
not much maybe now is going to play with
six or what is he doing
no I mean you can go a six here it
doesn't really help
oh okay
yeah I'm going to reroute this bishop
yeah the bishop is not good on b7 so I'm
going to just put it here right in the
middle of the position shop coming to d3
maybe that must be in something good for
me
now yeah just a five before this is
where I'm winning on the queenside
or hopefully I'm winning
very odd game a white
giving up center porn and then not even
trying to get compensation
um okay
let's go be form
you
I sorry I expect him to play a form
trying to keep the side of the board
closed
or you can just ignore everything here
possible
but I don't see is compensation okay
Oh
I'm answering this I can check it all of
it
yeah okay I'm taking and now you will
take c6
to know what
and I don't even mind to return the
exchange if I can just get the Queen to
defy for example that would be
absolutely outstanding
you know but she just
enough anyway here for the exchange
come on I'm returning this
maybe he doesn't want to take
d5
you
you
[Music]
you
okay so I'm going to go is six
if he takes the rook I'm just happy with
the light squeeze which completely
dominating
okay it does just doesn't want to take
it which I hear which I understand in
some way but okay but where are you
going now it's not that the bishop has
many squares
somewhere here a four
you know
you
okay
b3 would cut off the bishop completely
but I don't know I'm ever attacking it
still not bad just come on let's just
cut this off and ask white about his
next idea oh and see that one it's a bit
embarrassing but ok the resulting
position is just extremely good for me
so it's not a big deal
also could have taken me five but looks
it was good
a little bit behind on the clock so
speeding up a bit is not too bad
hmm yeah I can take e5 I think I
actually should take it
getting rid of that somewhat hmm
somewhat limiting pawn
of the good
with a ticket here
and Roxy too
got no good square to go to
you
what on earth it takes you to
yeah you never know maybe you just got a
phone call or something like that
you
yeah unfortunately we have to wait I
actually have a tear just not
not quite ready yet ISIL has to sit for
a moment
Jinja team need some minutes and I
didn't really get the best ginger this
is really I learned to appreciate the
differences I've gotten the first one
that I got like two weeks ago when I was
having this cold
that was from I'm not what's going on
here
um the the that one I got from I'm not
sure what the English term is like we
have a supermarket for organic food I
think that's the right one I always find
that sounds weird but this kind of
higher priced yam buy or whatever stuff
and this was extremely good ginger and
now I've got something here from from
yeah from Aldi yeah you probably know
that Rd is pretty much international
nowadays and this is not even that much
cheaper actually and it's really bad in
comparison that's really bad in
comparison said unrated noise did I mean
it is okay but it's it's really a
substantial difference
well next time I'm going to take the
effort and go to them
organic food store or the ginger
this is not bad actually it is a five
on push looks a little bit odd but it's
not bad at all
white can only count on a pretty small
advantage in such a position just have a
little bit more space which is defining
the advantage but it is nothing
extraordinarily grade
there is an interesting way to play we
just go d5
I mean this Inn is kind of useful for
like
well let's keep the tension
you
you
a good d5 now I'm problem
or we have to face night a five
and I'm not certain about this if the
night is good on that square or compared
to many other lines the a pawns are not
on the board anymore
now by the way what happens if I take
and now play night a four
I just play against the queenside
formation
you
it feels like
reasonable choice
yeah
you
I felt that this cannot be great but
maybe I'm wrong
score 95
opening up the long diagonal
this one I mean
they were probably
I think
rook g8 maybe can be played
night xe6 is a good intermediate move
be much killing off flex pawn structure
I expect him to take
more to learn
what yeah I don't know it's not so
difficult this decision okay goes to B
form
I didn't expect this one to happen
isn't this annoying
angling form no goes back okay
I can take before now
it's not completely clear decision but
interesting now just claim that before
is a weak pawn
problem pretty justified claim
looks like I have some good chances to
just pick it up
with cream takes before ideally this
watch
keep some pressure
hmmm don't understand this move what's
going on here should age six
to sit there what is the idea here
Bishop g4
no don't get it 94
Wow I have absolutely no idea what what
this is what this is about
looks completely random to me
yeah we will trade quince know him and I
should just be better a lot
now yeah he's attacking this I can go
rook d1 this is probably the simplest
way to do this
you know yeah we look just
tricky stuff
it's not even such a big issue but I
should have taken account that this is
possible
probably taken g2
what else is there to do
Bishop d3 routing wanders route d6 I
guess which is annoying
okay
[Music]
okay just
trade this off and play with a pawn up
we should be for ages playing for one
move tricks this is basically the whole
game
you
it's still not completely trivial to win
because a bishop before i blundered we
should before
just silly
just so silly
very fortunate that he didn't spot this
and he should have I mean he played for
there was kind of one movers the whole
time so the moment that I actually
allowed one he should use this
you know the good thing is that with the
increment at least he cannot
just play random stuff and try to win on
time
not completely simple to win
Shapira is pretty annoying
you
you
you
you
trying to go here have any to go and
play against the pawns
pawns that are on dark squares
what he's doing
you
you know I don't really want to play e5
um if I'm not sure I think I have to
Oh
I was truly odd game and I blundered the
bishop he actually could have won this
game which is crazy considering how it
went
laying something else this is not a bed
line at all
you usually don't get there actually as
widest typically not allowing this
particular variation
John
yeah got them
not like black is better but white
usually does not want to allow a form
and have a space disadvantage it can
often easily turn into just some kind of
a French Defense reversed not quite
because white managed to play Bishop g5
you
you
let's get this traders
you
dumb for me just back
with this age formal white um
yeah more or less and said that he was
not going to play a three anytime soon
and this is important
oh my
space advantage she is probably going to
persist
Oh interesting
one Jim
edmond
you touch
7 c 5 check bishop f 7
you know I'm happy with the bishop here
michael 6 or not
doesn't really matter
I always have C 5b 5c 5 is good
I'm covering the pawn Adam
what are you doing there
this is one of those opponents where I
never understand a move so I'm just
going to play I'm just going to play my
own game because it's useless
I will never guess a move that he's
going to play
Oh King g7 row gauge a g5 has my plan
and he's doing something
I'm not saying it is bad you know it's
just like I will never guess a move
so just go ahead with your own game and
let the other guy do whatever he wants
but sometimes the right practical
attitude like this year this is a move
that I would never consider remotely
but yeah so now he's going to take on c6
and then what would then probably
nothing
you know okay I mean I mean it's not
like I'm winning after g5 happens but so
watch g5
what is going to do this one
let's go here
and then see what happens
maybe a five a six yeah this looks like
a good one doesn't do it
okay
each
you
sorry I completely overlooked this
- here it's maybe not the end of the
world because I threatened rook age -
um I just completely didn't see it
Oh gauge to us I have a pretty
substantial threat
which is completely ignored of course
what is he doing is to set so dangerous
I don't know
to play this come on
okay so look each one maybe
I've got 94
eh one
I should really think about 94 sometime
okay let's go here
you
form
pretty pretty tense position here
buh-bah community 7 I have no clue
really what's going on
it takes the pawn really
okay
it's super metrid istic
with all its pieces being dead here I
think
so he says you can defend everything
maybe he can
maybe he can
[Music]
you
we'd be seven I have 95
you
and no I'm threatened I cheat or
9f2 I mean
how do you defend against this
winces seven probably
question is can I do something better
which is answered by the check
you
you
maybe not maybe not
this is a really nice way to cover it
maybe this one I have to make a move I
just have 20 something seconds
you take them to check actually
the night on g-form so that if five is
covered
you
Renea able to crazy everything
the night is covering everything here
remarkable
you
let's try to push the f-pawn
okay
you
is discovered actually
yes this covered
don't see a move
you
you
you
and now it's got this bloody porn
running all over the place okay I have
this covered for the moment and now I
can enter with my night
check
you
I don't see you in
absolutely don't see Owen
raising Quincy - there's no mate I don't
see a maid
probably there is there something is
there when I have to check this quickly
no no it's a direction it's whether you
draw yep if everything I mean then ever
they probably had everything here from
both sides winning multiple times
so I'm really curious about this
disposition yeah if there's something so
this this is winning but I couldn't
quite make it work night except to now
is one win
eggs cakes Queen h4
yeah McKim so I'm just doing it to
slowly not safe
and rook G 2 is actually winning I mean
it's not like it's not but this is this
is just a draw unfortunately they have
to take with the night now
yeah I was always
pretty much sold on the idea that I have
to come in five but the the engine is
just very mercilessly doing this and now
their white is running out of chicks Wow
Oh
so let's play let's play some more
you
yeah still taste him but it's really not
the best stuff okay so can we get a new
game
Oh
and let's get started
or maybe not
you
I'd really worked out quite well last
time I just got to have read the pawn
and the game I haven't looked at this
for I mean for ages so
[Music]
you
don't worry I'm not going to make a draw
can
continue with black indisposition
mmm-hmm that makes quite a bit of sense
let's see if I can get some counter play
now with the king side being somewhat
somewhat weakened by white
I know so let's say I take it
no it's some
it's some counterplay
so I'm going five I'm not quite sure
about this but
he just doesn't care
mmm okay whenever it takes I have see I
can take c5 at the end
to keep the tension a little bit him
after afore he has to go all the way
back you know all the way back
no it's not actually I can do that I can
do that I just spotted something let me
check this Eve for
before night back 9065 is what I saw
yeah this is actually more complicated
than it looks because after 95 taking
Bishop c3 is simple but he has Bishop to
d6
this is the the whole whole issue
you
you can sacrifice in exchange here it's
not
completely outlandish
really like like I would really like
you win c5
important pawn my real issue is Knight
takes Bishop e6 amber moved the night
away and then he goes c4 that's the
thing that could prevent c4 I would
sacrifice us instantly
but he's got this bloody c4 move and
then I really have to go backwards the
whole time
maybe it's still good okay I cannot
really resist this
now Bishop d6 96
okay
a bishop d6s the only move anyway what
you see in doing it okay now
[Music]
night a for takes bishop takes still see
form
still the bloody Seaforth
yeah I shouldn't have done that
it's just too tempting somehow to take
readies Godsey form that's the problem
if he allows me to play b5 I have really
good compensation but it's not going to
do it
cake when a phone
you
I have some play it's not like I'm I
have nothing but it's not extremely
convincing one point here is that yes
this weekend King side with g4 so one
idea is that this move now becomes
possible but he has Bishop g2 which is
awful not awful that it is it saving
white let's aim
now 93
it's a bit of a bummer
you
and I spent unbelievable amounts of time
coming coming to this decision to
sacrifice the exchange
you
[Music]
maybe maybe
it's still going to be interesting now
Bishop before coming
in g4
now I have enormous compensation
probably more than enough
you
so I have to move quickly yeah it's
fantastic actually Queen age for you
cannot prevent and I have Bishop d6 as
well
g1i take on edge for night h3 Bishop d6
checkers annihilation absolute
annihilation
still this exchange sack was not a
correct decision
when g2 mate now is the threat
you
and Queen h4 mate after work g1
you
that's it
you
it's really made next move right
don't see what he does it's made on age
402
there was a bit lucky that was not a
correct
sacrifice
you check this quickly I am I really
don't know I mean the computer actually
says that it's right but it wants to
play 97 now 97
and yes this
and then just play the position okay I I
do understand I mean it's not like my
sacrifice was completely bogus I did it
like this and basically claim that I
have enough strategic compensation we
nee for is dislike the Queen da test
engines recommendation the compensation
is based on a couple of things I've got
good space and this is really weak and
tough to fix and I've got the bishop Pam
yeah there are a couple of things and
impacts favor that compensate but it's
it's not completely convincing so here
c5 is a lot better
ooh c5 my queen out
ouch it would have been terrible
after this it's probably okay I mean I
also during the game I felt this could
be okay
or given us fairly equal and now I had
to play quickly
and somewhere here white is probably
losing the threat
you can play YUM this is just
it's not good
and she adds its completely winning
made in X if you give it enough time -14
already
probably jumping to mate in 12 or
something and some some seconds yeah
here your ear just toast
it was a bit of an odd game really but
okay interesting one so let's go back
here and
play one or two more
Oh
died DD go Don died golden who knows
who knows
you
yeah this ad on the board million times
it feels
it's a pretty good line against 1c form
and it's not
a lot of efforts to learn so one point
you
got a good fairly simple to handle
development
Bishop is 6
[Music]
v6 age six
this is surprisingly not a problem black
can even do this
at the end of the day this also c4
hanging
okay
you
now it should be
should be okay
only about equal disposition
mmm he allows this interesting
it's probably not a problem but
still not something that I would have
expected that here
just allows response to be doubled
no it should be fine for me
tomorrow try to use this as weakness
maybe night f5
right a five for 25 or 40 for maybe
deform
the cava threaten Oh
not quite a threat but it looks like one
let's see how he is handling this
you
yeah do we play d4 here or not
when g5 is probably not really doing
much
five is hanging
it's let's try to annoy him on this side
of the board
mmm
now I can take
I got this check
does or if it does much
same
- maybe h4
it looks at at Ted annoying for white
G 493 for example
probably not something you're happy to
see oh okay what is he doing there Queen
g5
the idea
[Music]
it is dangerous
you
I can just go back to g6 was my damage
nothing special really
maybe you can just pay h4 and
[Music]
I need to get rid of the Queen this is
just not acceptable
okay let's say I can't take it
Knight takes
you
[Music]
right
great
you
have to trade the bishop that is so
necessary subsea six
yeah I saw that a bit too late that this
could be an idea
not totally certain if it works but
probably does
Bishop h5 bishop c6 check is called for
this one
really
I has got to check on b6 as well shoot
you
arrrooo could be 6a
you
Wow
you
right if seven was a nice one
and I saw that far too late
is not fun
put it mildly
[Music]
you
you
you need to cover the seventh-ranked
here
if you just have one look I have
reasonable chances to draw
you
let's get a bit of count to play with
the actor hook
probably wants to go to a forum
you
not sure if es the way forward can
detect the porn but I can then cover it
with the king it's probably okay for me
you
you
you
yeah I send the porn is a bit quicker
I'm here his pawn but
you
okay no that's no problem at all
you
there is no way to play for wienie or
anything I was just checking of this
something that I can do but not really
you
yeah droid and I don't know
I mean I was never better or anything
and probably just lost at one point it's
very much possible so let's go for one
more game
one more game
you
takes a moment
now we get it I can go for maybe for a
chart for a change
Needham
exchange
people playing those ambitious
variations
gives white good chances to try for an
edge
now I think f6 is the move it's been a
while since I looked at this going to be
really
Oh
so what's going on a three
let's digest as form
hello things are possible here for sure
[Music]
a three crane a five yes this bishop
takes a three IDM
you
ninety-two was also something I would
like to play with deform really seems to
be hanging
vicuna 592 should be three just works I
think
odd
you
yeah this is not what I wanted obviously
but I couldn't find a better solution in
the context or blitz game
still think that YouTube I'm better
development in space can play play this
position for
or small edge
but it's not what I
and I think you probably and do better
against screen before but I couldn't
quite piece it together this is very
strange
really I always have to play f6 in this
kind of game because the knight coming
to e5 is such a problem
you
huge issue here is that the bishop on g6
is coming into is getting into some
trouble it has no squares to go to and F
3 and then H 4 is going to be very
annoying the other thing that I can try
is f4 but then he can probably play can
probably play Bishop before
no actually not then this is just very
strong
f-five is a huge threat
should before just fails to Knight takes
f7
I mean take on the form then night xf7
winning the exchange move Knight f6 was
really strange
you have to play with f6 in such a
position maybe nighty 7 then f6
you
if I take it pawn takes
knight of seven no
it doesn't really make a difference
right I can just do this
I mean the funny thing is that da de
says I used to hang with chick
so
got this and now let's see how we go
into how are we converting this into
cover
the night only four is pretty strong
though
I might consider to give the exchange
back on your form
that comes into consideration
if form you put this pawn on a dark
square
you
don't mind
you
opening up my bishop cannot be bad I
think
you
but still go to e5 I guess
or maybe we get this
this into motion
you
it's not it's not like I'm promoting it
so quickly
and simplify
you
now as I've saw wait you
simplify the technical matters here I
think
should be now simply to win
my king should control the pawn
oh yes
[Music]
have to watch out a little bit
you
seven
No
actually miscounted this
hmm
oh my
that was pretty awesome technique I mean
I think I think it still wins actually
because I'm just approaching with the
King and Windows pawns but still it was
pretty bad
take this
okay seven I've rook F seven
and cover this first
you
yeah that was not the best technical
playroom but it will at the end it will
be enough
you
not good not good yeah I mean I would
like to check one or two things after
movie form the computer likes
Knight H form yeah here you can do that
let's get rid of the bloody bishop
and my my continuation is probably not
terrible because he still has to do
something he has to play
I think night I thought night g7 would
be right but this is also bit better for
white I just get the bishop and I got F
for coming
this is just not playable after this you
just lost
through my technical play was abysmal I
should probably take on this heaven
immediately f7 immediately but okay this
is not bad
should just probably return the exchange
in a different way so I just want to
check this a little bit
yeah I wonder
it should be enough but I'm not playing
it right
you know okay I can just keep them sure
that that's true but maybe this is not
actually that easy
okay six many moves win probably what I
did also but it's not exactly great you
know it just takes are too long and
now c5 is a draw
see for might still win
see five is a draw it's not exactly to
reveal
yeah that just kids comes to a dead end
young
and then this is probably losing you
because of this exactly the sequence of
the game okay so let's go for one more
game and then call it a day
David 1717
you
no move today
you
okay
wills ish builds ish
you
you
you
you
you six Wow
this is actually a line at the Christmas
tree variation I know it sounds odd but
it's really what it's called black going
for queen is seven business Oh
and going five
[Music]
or 94
she fought as possible
I know I'm just
just to pawn up or not much
okay
yeah come on let's cover the c-pawn so
that I can play Quincy to next
you
I mean it wasn't really hanging but
it just makes them good harmonious
impression to play three
just supports
hold stability of the position
you
a three is a pawn that you can also take
why not
we have Bishop c5 is an exchange
No
[Music]
or can he play the data said something
that he can do
actually and it's not really necessary
to do this
I have complete control in this position
c6 is hanging a3 is hanging and I will
need to go into any kinds of
complications
you
he really wants me to take with the
bishop so okay let's do it
now with the rukon be one after a
potential night move and yeah I mean I
can't a key for here right
so take this
you
ftk I guess what else
you
not quite sure what he's saying
what did he expect that I resigned after
Knight takes even 94
what is the deal he has to take the
Queen anyway and then take only for
anyway he takes with the the Queen
oh that's funny okay
you
okay so go here
you
before
look before
when c5 mini
you
so what's the the simplest way to win
this position
mmm yeah actually I should have gone
here anyway
it would have been better that I work t1
because if you just
go for a three year should be simplest
you
let's go for the a3 pawn
you
still not quite
done with my stiff neck pre
pretty annoying really
you
[Music]
you really has lots of
in this position or okay now I resigned
much time but we have a new video I come
I can go home one more
17 it's bad but okay let's go for one
more game
Wow that that's a line that I thought I
would never meet because it's so
uncommon
but I caught it on the board
not so bad
ninety-two is a bit of a strange one
though
okay
you
but sweat this placement is really
awkward
time to
[Music]
organized
no wonder is why is he not just taking
on f6
is there really something else
otherwise I'll just win if five right
maybe he's kind of okay
not going to
not going to not take it's a bit weird
Englishmen not going to ignore the e5
pawn
I don't know here you just take on f6
this is just a pawn down form not much
I really analyzed that for the play like
Magnus repertoire tuba should be three -
it's a bit odd but it's not so bad if
you play it correctly
but I can would Indian with an extra
tempo or some kind of like c-45 and then
with d6 Bishop e7 f5 this is the play of
a line this is the same thing with an
extra tempo yeah now white is taking
ages and it's really too late I mean not
the position is not lost but it's too
late to really start to fix it and
trying to be okay
maybe you can play Bishop f4
now then I can't a completely five salt
so bad
maybe not
yeah in any case it's it's just an extra
point in the center
I just really not
playing him
I'm so
each one is a bit mysterious
you
a question Asst
-
yeah if 5mm if five is a little bit
weakening
on the other hand it's
you know it's so much space
the thing is Bishop g3 is now that that
position must be fantastic I can just
take and play Queen d6 let's say and the
vehicle was somewhere I'm 2 f2 or e1 I
always have this e5 idea threatening g4
okay now I can play Queen 36
but
yeah this is
looking better threatening g-form
26 threatening eform it's a bit naive
windy 6 but
yeah it's a developing move sort of with
the tempo
you
don't really see any active
possibilities for white
here Bishop c6
forward
you
I have really good
control you over the the squares m25
hey can he play he can play Queen f3
doesn't look like it blunders anything
is into it
you
you
yeah
or what
no reason not to
you
Wow
to
that's that's doesn't really help
you
I can simply take one afterward I wonder
ever have something better
we recklessly getting the night
to f3 is the kind of thing that you want
you
look F to Bishop F to 93 years is a neat
tactic
but he will take with the rook of course
you
just oh you didn't take the look
and what is the thing what are you doing
here
okay I thought that was not very I
thought the chances of this being
successful were not so high but he
actually overlooked the idea
the worst that could happen to me was
some kind of trade ok come on let's go
for the rematch
the video is getting longer than I
thought
what we get a classical - maybe
on this one ago yeah
Oh
it's odd
you
don't think you go night you form
just to trade it
you
why does that work
you
see somehow get this back
I don't see how he gets it back
even g4 sometimes can be on
maybe four
let's give away a pawn to activate
No
okay
you
we can go 94
somehow
no this is running right into my idea I
mean
that move I wanted to play anyway
mr.
corn
you
now these these lines in the Dutch with
d6
the classical Dutch and early 94 and so
on they are borderline incorrect anyway
and if you do something slightly
slightly secondary then then you're
often just killed
Tim when this is pretty sad position
Wow
ouch
no age forum
you
oh my
you
this is the only move that somehow
continues this a little bit
so Bishop g5 still
it's still hanging on there but you can
play this
take let's check this maybe I have
something better
yeah but it is school enough
this is definitely good enough
you
g5
you
I can even get a pawn to f6 which is
kind of kind of weird you never get get
these kind of things that already
already in the game usually
so just f6
[Music]
can also check here first it's it's so
so strange and check let's check first
cannot even interpose here I can just
check check here checky 555 and over oh
man
now how do we win down
g6 is close
if I go here
and where is he going he has to cover g6
the g6 threat
yes
chick
Shakeel if a bishop d5 shake
[Music]
you
yeah Bishop takes a five is almost
most possible
you
kill
you
but the best that I could find I mean
it's it's enough I think but I was
checking if I find something better and
I didn't
so just take the rook I guess
you
now where is the actual wind
I mean like my mates I have a look I'm a
rook up but
I was really thinking I should be a maid
somewhere
you
why just taking seven I guess
just win the Queen
you know okay stumbled into this opening
which is not really playable I guess
after a five drops okay guys I hope you
enjoyed another one of those blitz
sessions I'll be back tomorrow I hope we
bye take care